s
de Mathieu Dion.
NICOLAS BEETZ,
chef des opérations, Lolë
- Avant COVID, nous avions
30 magasins comme celui-ci...
- Et du jour au lendemain,
avec le confinement,
les difficultés financières
déjà présentes deviennent
trop lourdes à porter pour Lolë.
L'entreprise montréalaise
de vêtements de sport se met
à l'abri de ses créanciers
et se restructure complètement.
Il ne reste aujourd'hui
que quatre boutiques
en Amérique du Nord,
mais les affaires vont mieux.
- On a beaucoup, beaucoup moins
de dépenses. Donc le service
aussi de ventes en ligne
a explosé, car nos produits
c'est des produits qui sont très
en demande présentement suite
à faire du yoga à la maison,
à faire des activités
extérieures.
- Les grandes bannières avec
de nombreux magasins et
leurs coûts fixes sortent
péniblement de la pandémie.
Parmi les fermetures :
l'enseigne Le Château avec
ses 123 succursales
et 1400 travailleurs.
L'industrie du vêtement à
Montréal, troisième pôle
sur le continent après
Los Angeles et New York,
demeure malgré tout résiliente.
DEBBIE ZAKAIB, dg
Grappe métropolitaine de la mode
- La diversification
de l'approvisionnement,
par exemple, l'accélération
de la performance numérique.
Ça nous a permis de s'améliorer,
de devenir plus compétitif.
- Le propriétaire de Lola Jeans
a déménagé sa production
de l'Asie au Mexique pour
se différencier et offrir
un denim plus écoresponsable.
DAVID ABISSIDAN,
président, Lola Jeans
- On a dû vraiment se recycler
rapidement, se réinventer.
Une chose qu'on a fait,
c'est de renforcer notre
présence en ligne.
- C'est une compagnie de
Londres...
- L'Agence JLG, qui agit comme
intermédiaire entre
manufacturiers et détaillants,
a observé une autre tendance.
STÉPHANIE GAUTHIER,
copropriétaire, Agence JLG
- Ce que nous ont a vu dans
nos boutiques indépendantes
au Québec, c'est que des gens
ont commencé à faire des storys,
des live Facebook, Instagram,
de vendre en ligne à tous les
types de clients...
- Donc, j'ai l'Avenue Paris
capuchon en cinq couleurs...
- ...y'a des femmes disons
de 50 ans qui magasinaient pas
nécessairement en ligne avant
la COVID.
- L'agence a tout de même perdu
30 % de son chiffre d'affaires :
certaines marques étrangères ont
cessé de distribuer au Canada
et des clients à l'aube de
la retraite ont préféré
mettre la clé sous porte.
- L'industrie est plus fragile,
elle va le rester encore pour
la prochaine année.
- Évidemment, avec la pandémie,
le télétravail, y'a moins
de demande pour les complets,
comment a été votre année?
HICHAM JERANDO,
président, Jerando Fashion
- C'était une année vraiment
difficile. Comme vous le savez ,
Y'a pas seulement
le télétravail. Y'a plus
de mariages, y'a plus
restaurants, y'a plus de partys.
- En cinq ans, Jerando avait
réussi à ouvrir cinq magasins
dans le Grand Montréal.
trois ont dû être fermées.
- Heureusement, on a fait
un virage vers les masques qui
a sauvé un petit peu la business
parce qu'on a été capable
de payer les loyers.
- La production de
ces vêtements là,
c'est des blouses d'isolation...
- Vêtements Peerless a dû
temporairement fabriquer
des équipements de protection
pour les travailleurs de
la santé afin de poursuivre
ses opérations. Bien loin
des complets Calvin Klein
et Tommy Hilfiger qu'elle
confectionne normalement.
LOUIS ARSENAULT, dir. RH,
Vêtements Peerless
- Graduellement les ventes
d'habit ont repris, à un très
faible niveau pour par la suite.
- Seulement la moitié des 1000
employés sont donc à l'ouvrage.
- On a quand meme adapté notre
produit à la nouvelle réalité
du marché, on a de plus en plus
des vêtements qui sont souples,
des vêtements qui sont un peu
plus déconstruit avec un look
un peu plus sport.
- Les vêtements seront toujours
indispensables, mais beaucoup
auront probablement découvert
les vertus du cotton ouaté
et de son confort.
Ici Mathieu Dion,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.